reason I just never 100 games was
because I did it once with Tails and
then I was like never again never 100
Tales game
I loved that to me
you know you can remember back in the
day when you only had like that one game
to play until next Christmas sure like
to me for me that was tails that was
when I had time and I was like I don't
know what to do I have no idea
like having like like having to go
somewhere for like one day was like made
me a busy man yeah I could spend the
rest of the days playing video games I
was like taking that one day thing
I'm like bro I'll kill Stacy games now
I'm like I will kill for one hour yeah
sure I wouldn't do anything for an hour
sure yeah it's really weird for me with
the video games because I could never
play for like one or two hour stints it
always if if I if I have a video game I
like I need to play for at least like
four hours oh man I've been able to
enjoy a game for like 20 minutes and
then just do something else is hype bro
it takes me 20 minutes just to get like
invested into like the game well that's
why overwatching games like that are
pretty fun because you can just do like
two games 30 minutes go back to whatever
you're doing pretty nice so I just play
module
out of it you want to reset your brain
you want to like kind of just take your
mind off what the work is for like 20 30
minutes yeah I mean maybe you don't want
to take it then like one game turns into
like two games I'm pretty good
but then at that point I'm just like
well I'm five games on margin
bro like going on tour with Connor off
entire hold up no no that's different
that is different because uh our
entirety's highest schedule revolved
around whether Conrad started a game of
Kia [ __ ] tea or not we would be like
yo kind of rehearsals in five minutes
Connor's like but but I just don't I
just started the game I just started a
game of DFT guys I never played near our
rehearsal time that's a [ __ ] lie no
no no and most I would push you back
five minutes that's that's not true I
would play a lot of TFT because we
didn't really have anything to do a lot
of the time yeah so I was like oh just
gain but in normal work it's like I will
pretty much I will work from like nine
to ten Non-Stop and then I'll have to
take a break at some point and play some
games because always I'll get my brain
will be like wait 9am to 10 a.m 10 p.m
okay I was about to say I'm like I'll
work yeah
I don't know I normally have to like
stream and then I'm like all right I
have to do real work yeah I'm gonna
answer emails too much fun I gotta I
gotta feel like I didn't have fun yeah
exactly don't speak for yourself stream
is like pure gamer right here streamers
definitely worked for me yeah streams
work for me I don't actually like it
it's fun
yeah I don't know it depends on the game
for me I was thinking like should I
stream god of war and I was just like no
I just because I I wanted to just be
like immersed in the game and just say
like damn this show is really good think
of the five Subs yeah yeah the only way
that we'll be able to get through the
trail series is if we stream till last
year like realistically so that's the
thing right if there's a game that is
too long it makes no sense to play it
off stream because you know it's a big
time thing so you should play but then
there's no point doing it on stream
either because then viewers will just
fall off yeah true maybe yeah maybe
because I tried to do that with Yakuza 7
and like after 11 streams people just
don't care so I'm like [ __ ] it I'll just
finish this game depends on the game
because like you know Pokemon it makes
sense right yeah because it's like you
can just tune in whenever you
immediately know what the [ __ ]
happening there's no concrete story you
can just immediately be like oh you're
trying to catch some Pokemon cool I'll
join in but like you know 10 streams
into Yakuza 7 where it's like the story
is pretty much fleshed out at that point
it's like oh I don't know what the [ __ ]
is happening therefore I'm not gonna
stay I think people need to enough
people need to have played a game or has
to have like a really hardcore fan but
it's like you know Final Fantasy online
or you know genjin even you know
invention streamer against you because
that's why you're such an easy great
country that streamer yeah streamer that
plays that game yeah yeah it's such an
investment and that you know anyone who
would want to watch would also be
interested in that game yeah yeah well
yeah honestly it's it's also games
especially as well so you know who's
going to be the world's first Trail
stream
there's got to be one out there right no
one cares don't do that do not do that
because like Trails I'm like this this I
see some light trails and I'm just like
this will never ever ever be popular but
holy [ __ ] it like it just speaks to me
there's five Japanese dudes somewhere in
the world who are like the hot most
hardcore Trails fans who are just like
please give it to me the more I get into
streaming the more I want to do non-game
streams like the more I want to do like
I want to go fishing yeah that's the
that's the OG game yeah
and I eat today like I feel like I want
to play the analog like I'm more
interested in streaming like classical
stupid [ __ ] like like fishing or like
outdoor stuff that I think is like kind
of games or like you know games before
games yeah you know activities games
that don't involve videos yeah yeah I
don't know why they must discover yeah
Gamers be like wait games existed before
games hey you're like yo the graphics of
this fishing game it's really weird this
is just fishing
I don't know why the more I'm like real
life stuff seems more fun I don't know
why real life stuff is great but what
are they gonna patch is a mechanic man
yeah I can't believe fishing
the time the fish is too long like the
fish the fish is like too much RNG man
uh they're like this this is just like
gotcha but like [ __ ] yeah so I've
done I've actually done fishing a few
times in Japan now all right I did the
fishing with mailing in the ocean yeah
uh that was that was [ __ ] hard mode
fishing that was just hard much harder
than uh Lake fishing lake fishing and
River fishing is nice I like it that's
like the perfect battle Yeah you you get
fishes uh at a good Pace yeah you know
and it's much more relaxing as well yeah
yeah you can sit down on the boat you're
like [ __ ] oh God am I gonna get a
fish I don't know for like four hours
and then you don't get any fish because
yeah you're like you just see sick and
wet it's just [ __ ] yeah and then you
can't like you want to go to the toilet
you have to go in this shitty little
boat like I just I everything about it I
just want to piss off the edge of the
boat dude yeah yeah we're gonna I went
on this uh fishing thing with Maylene
and it was it was fun it was just too
long it was like it was like eight hours
on like on the water I had done it three
hours man yeah because I went like Lake
fishing again after when like sea
fishing would mail in and I just
realized damn Lake fishing is just it
it's just so much more chill and I'm
like the friends who made along the way
yeah and I go see fishing I was like oh
this is why fishing is a job you know
because it's hard hard work
I'm wet I'm soaking and you know I we'd
be I'd be there for hours right and I
would be staring at these like old
Japanese men who are like nuts at it and
I was literally copying everything they
were doing I thought they had the straps
I wasn't doing it because like I I would
I swear to God I would like literally
one for one mimic exactly what he was
doing and I could not get a fish to save
my life I got like two fish total this
these dudes bro it was like that's like
that's like being like you know oh I'm
gonna play Dark Souls and watch this
Dark Souls speedrunner no I just do
exactly what they do I recognized it
like I'm definitely not these dudes have
been doing it their whole life yeah yeah
and the thing that I liked about like in
sea fishing was really [ __ ] hot
because the technique matters a lot yes
um whereas in a lake you're like
plop yeah wait and then that's it it's
good it's fun you can chat you can chill
out you want to drink a bit you've got
to like pull it you're pulling it yeah
these dudes are nuts dude these Japanese
men I mean it's in it's in the blood man
it is a generation man throws it in two
seconds got like five on one hook I'm
like what the [ __ ] is happening man and
he's just like at a pity he's like
here's a fish genuinely
like bro I've caught too many I'm like
hey you want one yeah sea fishing was
just frustrating for me because I'm like
what the [ __ ] am I doing wrong I
actually have no idea what I'm doing
insane yeah a million's been a ton and
million wasn't getting anything right
don't you do this often shouldn't you be
getting more fish yeah because I did
exactly the same way where there were
some Japanese men like catching like
literally a bucket full of fish yeah I
like mimic everything they're doing the
right way nothing yeah I throw it in
nothing throw it in nothing because they
had the the [ __ ] like cracked fishing
pole that's what I'm guessing yeah yeah
yeah I had the the school the school uh
Sports Hall fishing pole they're like
yeah we got a pole we put a line on the
end yeah yeah I don't know you gotta
stick with a piece of strings they felt
so bad for us that when we docked and
went back in because you pay like 15
bucks to go out and fish yeah and you're
allowed to catch as many fish as you
want so there's some quarters they give
you free fish as well yeah the dude was
like
that's it yeah hold on we caught like a
ton the other day yeah it's a bag
I guess he just felt bad yeah yeah with
the same thing but it's all sauce as
well I feel them doing that is like
backhanded because like the game ring
you was like no I could do better I mean
it's not that I was fine just clarify
I'm not frustrated because I didn't get
enough fish I'm frustrated because I I
hated the whole the vibe of it and how
long you were dead like a rainbow yeah
and you know you you dock and then you
drive out on the boat for like an hour
yeah and you're just the sun because it
was in like August so the sun is
destroying you as well and you're like
this this [ __ ] sucks because unlike
unlike Lake fishing sea fishing is a
commitment you can't just be like oh
just just talk somewhere let's just
chill out you know somewhere and go yeah
no just just can't pull the camping
chairs and put the beer in yeah yeah
exactly I can't do that it's a
commitment and unfortunately the sea is
the sea you know and if if if you need a
place to rest you still like it's still
rocking a lot yeah because it's the sea
and it's a lot more intense than Lake
fishing I was actually like sweating at
a point doing uh doing sea fishing
because it's like it's a workout it's
it's so much more intense because you're
constantly having to do something
because oh passive activity it's an
active activity
um but you get you get like bigger fish
for it you know that's that's the
trade-off sometimes if you can catch it
yeah a little fish are fine too they
taste good yeah yeah they're fine
they're good so I want the five stars
though man I'm waiting for my first five
star man you have a catching big fish is
way harder than getting a little fish
like a lot lot more yeah yeah I know but
then we're not capable of that guy we
gotta stay in our lane 20 years too late
but I I just want to know what that
feels like you know I wanna I wanna know
I wanna know
yeah
us me Immortals we haven't been fishing
for like 20 years you can't get to we
don't get to do that no I don't know
there's other sports I really want to do
as well more I want to do more Sports
essentially as well I'm the same yeah
[Music]
incredible workout but I it just made me
realize how unfit I actually am oh yeah
um
I knew no I knew but like it just it
just reaffirmed my suspicions right
because it's like I was probably out
there for what maybe two hours yeah and
I was just [ __ ] destroyed like
because it's it's the part that it's
it's the paddling out that just takes
all the energetic no no and maybe it's
because like I heard I saw some people
you know saying like oh it's because you
were in like cold Waters and that just
saps the energy out of you more than
like summer warm Waters and stuff like
that but I think that's only up to a
certain extent like you need to be at a
certain level of Fitness but that's
actually you guys want copium yeah
that's copium it's like yeah you know
but um no it's really fun like even if
like I didn't I probably maybe caught
one wave and I didn't even stand up for
it obviously but like even just like
catching that one wave while on your
stomach it does seem hard it's it's hard
it is very hard but it's super [ __ ]
fun and like yeah I definitely want to
go back um yeah yeah so I remember
trying surfing for the first time as
well it's so much [ __ ] fun but like
you said you spend most of your energy
not actually doing surfing it's actually
like paddling out it's like getting out
because you have to like go against the
waves yeah you don't realize how much
energy that takes Until you realize you
spend all this energy to maybe like to
get one chance to catch like a wave
right and if you don't catch it then you
then you [ __ ] up and you gotta paddle
out all over again you know yeah so it's
it's a lot it's a lot of energy it's a
lot of waiting as well it's a lot of
waiting especially if like the waves are
kind of mediocre like it was when we
went yeah yeah um it's just like a lot
of like oh is it no oh is it no and
you're just sitting in the water for
maybe 30 minutes yeah freezing your ass
off right because you're not moving at
all and then the one burst of energy you
have to use to catch that wave that you
might not even actually catch yeah you
just get way close to the Sean you go oh
[ __ ] now to paddle back out again yeah
and use up all this energy it's like
with skiing or snowboarding it's [ __ ]
easy because uh like the [ __ ] ski
lift does all the work for you to get
yeah it's like it's like it's like if
you went skiing except the ski lift
wasn't lurking working and you had to
walk up yeah every time and then you
have to use all this energy for like a
tenth of the time to go down and be like
yeah well guess I gotta go all that up
all the way again where's the ski let's
do the surfing yeah
I'm like what's I wonder what outdoor
sports that are cool that would work for
streaming like okay surfing doesn't work
there's water if you are getting wet or
submerged it doesn't work anything like
that done kayaking could work but if you
go too far out to the ocean there's no
signal yeah yeah so you've got to kayak
around somewhere maybe in original
snowboarding maybe see okay I thought
about this I thought skiing or
snowboarding could could work and
technically it's possible but I wondered
would it look [ __ ] on camera because
it's literally just White
uh it's white and then you're going fast
down so there's like opportunities to
talk and stuff but I'm like I don't know
if it could be interesting you would
also need I guess maybe like a wide lens
to you know kind of capture you and the
rest of the thing because this is just
like the camera I have is very wide okay
it's really wide it might work yeah yeah
but I guess also like is there like but
like some mountains I know don't have a
great signal either yeah it depends it
depends depends on the mountain depends
on them I don't know I just want to do
more weird outdoor stuff no I can also I
just I want to do more Sports Outdoors
but it's hard to convince anyone I'm
down okay okay good good yeah I'll hold
you to that yeah lean mountain climber
because I went because I went surfing
with Felix and then the week after we
went to driving range
as [ __ ] it's like oh I actually kind of
missed doing this during the pandemic
because I just got so [ __ ] lazy
because we couldn't go outside didn't
couldn't move our body because no one
else was outside yeah all the places
were closed but now everything else is
open and people are like yeah I kind of
want to get back into shape or like I
kind of want to move my body I'm like
well let's [ __ ] go
I like trips that are like focused
around doing an activity right where you
like maybe go for two days to like kayak
somewhere yeah yeah to observe or
something I like that because I feel
like okay well it's a it's a holiday but
also you get to relax you do some
exercise it's like you've got to get
some endorphins
a lot of those sports that require that
like expensive or you need equipment or
someone's good to teach you around yeah
yeah a lot of the a lot of the sports
require knowledge entry points it's like
it's yeah it's the point of entry right
where yeah that's part of the reason I
never went skiing or snowboarding just
because you need someone who can help
you yeah the barrier Adventure was so
high yeah no one in my family ever skied
or snowboarded when I was younger so I
was just like well I guess uh I guess
I'm never going yes I'm never going yeah
that's true actually it for sure helps
yeah um I I wondered there's definitely
a scene for very odd extreme sports I
know there's like a scene for
um actually hunting in German really
yeah you can you can you can uh with
live animals or just like the other clay
pigeons live animals oh really you can
do it in Japan for some reason I've
stumbled across something and I was
reading about it it's quite interesting
it seemed like it's you have to it's a
very long process to get a gun in Japan
yeah it is um but it can be done and you
can hunt in Japan didn't know there was
a scene for hunting in Japan I didn't
think so either yeah I thought
everything was [ __ ] protected no no
no there's certain animals that you can
hunt oh certain Birds but know that fun
fact Japan often has a scene for very
like Niche Sports yeah but you need to I
wouldn't even know how you'd even begin
to get into stuff like that here that's
the problem it's like a lot of like I
feel Japan is the one country where
there are so many small cool little
niches that you can get into whether
it's like physical or just like hobby
based or something like that but like
it's either the point of entry is so
high or the community surrounding it is
so small and hidden or gatekeeping that
it's just like kind of hard to be like
can I join yeah you know without them
being like like oh you want to be a
train otaku name five trains it's like
it's like uh I don't know it's like [ __ ]
off you know it's like there's always
that because like because I wanted to do
a video on like kind of the weird like
you know like the the small little niche
otaku spheres like the train or tacos
but the problem is a lot of those people
just don't want to be public about it
and don't want to talk about it because
they don't want it to be like a
mainstream thing you know they want to
keep it in their small Niche I know that
some of the train attackers is that game
is that gatekeepy I don't know maybe
it's it it is geek yeah it totally is
what if that's just a Japanese mentality
of I don't really want to be on camera
um because I saw some of them on the if
you ever watched the James May Series in
Japan oh yes as long as you talked to
some train attackers and he was like I
need a TV products so why do you like
trains and they were like and he was
just saying so he's like all right
all right that's cool so I actually saw
a gun store in Japan
like live guns yeah like a gun store I
walked past a gun store and I was like
oh where was it shibia no I remember I
walked past it I can only think of the
one in [ __ ] yeah
I was thinking as well
I I remember walking past it and being
like that's a lot of guns wow and I was
like that like real guns not like real
real guns real guns definitely real guns
that was definitely real okay I remember
seeing because I saw the some of the
stuff outside and I was like oh yeah
that's real that's real [ __ ] because
airsoft guns they'll have what's the
word they call it they have um the
they'll have like Survival game written
over it so yeah yeah yeah I doubt real
guns would have Survival game with a
survival game yeah that's really cool
they call it hardcore yeah they call
Survival game in Japan yeah which makes
it sound way more hype than Airsoft see
Airsoft is a bad name I feel like it
makes it sound way wimpier than it
actually is yeah oh soft is it survival
games
and there's a bunch of airsoft bars in
Japan as well yeah
that was so much fun yeah yeah it was
very funny uh get going like
[Music]
I have one shotgun this is so much fun
oh yeah I heard you've been to one
before as well right I went to one in
Sendai yeah yeah there's if you go to
Japan maybe just Google Airsoft bars
they're pretty fun you can drink and
then shoot guns yeah yeah it's pretty
fun there's much in Tokyo isn't that
yeah yeah yeah that's I mean if you look
for very Niche odd bars there's so many
of them yeah just
I needed to shoot a grenade launcher in
my life but I now I did yeah I know I
knew that that was so much fun shooting
a grenade launcher and then being like
I'll have a sip of my drink now yeah
that was fun that was very fun I mean
talking about things about people to
Niche tastes it's like Japan is the
country of that oh yeah no 100 yeah not
just in video games but in every game
everything in real life real life real
life game the non-video games